life hasn't always been easy for you
Maui but you made sure that life would
be easy for everyone else you had your
reasons for stealing the hardest to be d
but your plan backfired big time take
off showed you who was buzz and put you
in the longest time out known to mankind
luckily Moana came out of the blue and
taught me what it means to be brave kind
and selfless chief mallanna of mote nui
was chosen by the ocean when she was
just a baby
she helped Maui become the demigod he is
today and humankind is forever grateful
but unlike Moana Maui didn't have the
best upbringing and we're about to tell
you why watch until the end to find out
why Maui and his arch nemesis Tama Toa
aren't so different after all
like most Disney heroes Maui story
doesn't start with rainbows and
butterflies but it sure ends that way
when Moana and Maui first meet he comes
off as a total villain he distracts her
by singing about his many
accomplishments only to trap her in a
cave and make off with her boat
luckily Burma wanna the ocean had her
back and after many failed attempts she
finally befriended Maui and returned the
heart of taffy tea to its rightful owner
but before that could happen Maui had to
deal with some of his many issues most
of which stemmed from his childhood
let's take things back a couple
millennia now he was born human just
like the rest of us but his human
heritage isn't something he likes to
talk about and for good reasons too
Maui's parents threw him into the ocean
minutes after he was born wanting
nothing to do with him so Maui grew up
feeling unwanted but grateful to those
who had saved him from the oceans debt
the gods plucked Phoebe Maui from the
sea gave him supernatural abilities and
turned him into a demigod the gods also
gave Maui a magical fish hook which he
used to shape-shift Maui grew up with
quite the reputation he was known for
his godly strength immortality in
tattoos but one thing the gods didn't
give Maui was his master sailor status
that he earned all on his own but
despite his many accomplishments Maui's
earliest memories still
despite having all the powers in the
world now he still felt rejected by
mankind so to earn their love he gave
them the most beautiful gifts a demigod
could offer
he pulled islands from the sea pulled
the Sun closer and stole fire from the
center of the earth to keep mankind warm
on cold nights now he got what he wanted
the humans celebrated and loved him from
afar but even then now he never allowed
himself to trust a human again
so when Moana turned up on his desolate
Island he heard her before she could
hurt him but long before Moana came
along now he did something that he would
forever regret he stole the heart of
taffy tea but in his own twisted way now
he did this out of love as it turned out
mankind began to take Maui's gifts for
granted so to keep their affections now
he had to find the next best gift and
here's where to feed his heart came into
play legend says the little gem has the
power to create life and now he wanted
to offer it to mortals all around the
world he never could have predicted that
taking the gem would result in darkness
slowly taking over the planet but he was
willing to do anything to feel loved and
appreciated by as many people as
possible
here's something you might find
interesting about Maui's dark pass if it
hadn't been for his parents twisted
actions the tangled universe probably
wouldn't exist
Disney loves to throw Easter eggs into
their movies and fans spotted the Sun
drop flower on two separate occasions
while watching Moana legend says that a
single drop of Sun fell from the heavens
and created the Sun dropped flower but
fans believe that this phenomenon
occurred when Maui pulled the Sun closer
to the earth so on top of thanking Maui
for the tides the Sun in the sky we
should thank him for princess Rapunzel's
awesome powers too but let's get back to
Disney's Moana Moana had more than a few
bargaining chips when she convinced Maui
to accompany her on her journey one of
them being that she was going to help
him retrieve his fish hook from Lalla
tie once Maui had his hook back he
started bonding with Moana but that all
changed when take ah damaged it in a
telling fit of rage Maui explained that
without his hook he was nothing the gods
rescued Maui and gave him a magical fish
hook which made him feel special
shoulde but without it Maui still felt
like an unwanted child who was thrown
away like he was nothing this revelation
was heartbreaking and it made us see the
relation between Maui and his rival Tama
Toa just like Maui Tama Toa covers up
his insecurities with shiny treasures
whereas Maui covers them up with
impressive tattoos in truth Maui bore
the same sadness as his rivals take ha
and Tama Toa but ignored the signs he
thought himself to be the hero of the
story but as it turned out he was the
villain but luckily for Maui the ocean
elected Moana
saved the world and Maui at the same
time she showed him what love and
compassion were all about and helped him
to become a better person Moana met take
ha head-on and told her that she wasn't
defined by those who had taken something
from her that's when Matt we realized
that patil ming comes from within giving
him the happily ever after he always
deserved who is your favorite disney
hero of all time
comment down below thanks for watching
subscribe to the things turn those posts
notifications on and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
see you next time
[Music]